donc floraux vous êtes ici pour votre
retour au cinéma avec un beau film de
jacques portal qui s'appelle quand je
vois le soleil avec marie claude
pietragalla françois cluzet alors on va
en parler mais d'abord je voudrais qu'on
parle un petit peu chansons
[Musique]
alors justement florent pagny avant de
parler de votre film je voudrais qu'on
fasse un petit bilan de votre promotion
de votre tournée des plateaux télé parce
que vous êtes un petit peu comme un
antoine moderne souvient antoine antoine
il passait son temps comme ça à faire du
bateau dans les îles de faim de
polynésie 1 la différence est cuit
antoine il avait un petit voilier de
merde élevé du nescafé comme ça le matin
dans une gamelle et vous vous avez quand
même 40 mille hectares en patagonie
alors ça fait rêver c'est clair c'est ça
ouais c'est sûr alors voilà
vous avez toile de luxe voilà bon
j'étais en fait moi je suis ça fait sept
ans que je vis là bas et j'ai jamais été
aussi présent je fais j'ai fait cinq
albums ans et mal donc
donc je fais plein de choses même si je
suis même si je suis là bas donc
j'arrive à me partager entre les deux et
voilà donc c'est mieux quand antoine bas
je sais gens peuvent voter chez eux
parce que c'est mieux quand toi est-ce
que c'est moins bien qu'en toi
saidal telle activité ces gens puissent
participer au fitton du direct le sms ça
fait du pognon
les chansons vous arrive là bas c'est à
l'extérieur par internet non c'est
extraordinaire en or 2003 qu
arriver aujourd'hui on en voit ce qu'on
appelle une petite machine s'appelle i
pod les analystes
c'est gros comme un paquet de cigarettes
tuent mais à peu près 200 albums dessus
de 1000 chansons trois mille chansons
donc tu voyages en n'ai pas écouté 3000
on en a le temps passé à peu près
300 qui sont arrivés sur une période de
pratiquement six mois tu vois j'ai pu
écouter ça tranquillement les choisit
alors d'être là bas c'est vrai que ça
inspire largement et ça permet de partir
dans des directions musicales qui sont
peut-être pas les mêmes vues que si
j'étais à paris bien sûr xavier betrand
l'aider retour médiatique et on retrouve
sur les plateaux toujours un peu mais
j'ai regardé un peu près toutes vos
promotions toujours un peu stone comme
ça un peu ailleurs est-ce que c'est leur
nom est ce que c est ce que c'est une
arme spéciale qui pousserait en
patagonie
rempl à nistos pas dit très fort en moi
bon c'est bah oui parce que vous êtes le
seul acteur le seul chanteur qui a des
problèmes avec le fisc et qui continue à
faire une carrière les autres ne
t'oublie de se barrer et paul-marie pour
ne plus jamais revu quoi charente le
dire je voulais rentrer les
environnements conduit par errer dans
les collines
c'est fou parce qu'en fait
j'ai pas de problème réellement enfin
c'est à dire si j'avais vraiment si
j'avais un vrai problème je serai pas là
donc c'est qu'il ya eu quelques erreurs
de commises de part et d'autre et qu'on
va trouver un moyen de s'entendre et que
quelque part ça permet suffisamment
d'avoir de recul et d'humour pour
pouvoir arriver même avec une chanson
qui traite de sade vers kobé y est son
redressement avec une chanson sur le
sujet n'a
cessé de se confirmer la règle et toute
ma vie c'était un peu comme ça tout va
vous arriver malgré vos problèmes avec
le fisc à à garder une bonne image ouais
mais bon en même temps je cache rien je
triche pas quoi j'ai une foi quand même
tapé chine mais non pas du tout
alors
qu'on m'accuse de tricher et que c'est
pas vrai que je réagis comme les lois
sont pas faites elles sont faites pour
tout le monde et quelque part on est des
cas particuliers donc les lois sont pas
faites pour nous ils le savent à chaque
fois qu'on va les voir il va on sait
qu'avec vous les uns toujours compliqué
les sportifs les artistes les gens qui
du jour au lendemain se retrouve avec
beaucoup d'argent bon c'est toujours un
sujet compliqué alors bon à un moment tu
dis attendez il extrait vu qu'ils
n'étaient pas comme les autres il
fallait pas qu'ils payent tout s'est
imposée génial ouais mais c'est vrai
enfin il fallait pas qu'il me redresse
de quelque chose n'allait pas me
redresse et bien moi je veux payer mes
impôts mais juste ce que je dois pas
cependant de se mettre d'accord il paye
parce que c'est foutu temps des demandes
beaucoup quand même et puis après si
jamais il se trompe il faut attendre
qu'ils admettre erreur à vendre alors
que toi si jamais un moment tu as un
problème tu te fais éclater plus les
pénalités plus la totale donc un moment
tu dis bon d'accord c'est un système qui
est plus fort que nous mais dites-moi
florence jamais rencontré sur un plateau
de télévision quelqu'un qui vous dit que
les impôts ça sert à payer les crèches
les hôpitaux que c'est vachement
important de payer des impôts quand on
gagne du pognon mais bien sûr mais moi
je dis je veux les payer moi je les paye
pas parce qu'on ne tombe pas d'accord
sur le
mais aussi le cri des ronds points je me
suis dit c'est mon argent c'est moi qui
me
voilà vous êtes ma mère regarde les
autoroutes par exemple [ __ ] de plus le
temps pour les casques avec tout ce
qu'on casse
si ça marche c'est ça non mais moi je
m'énerve pas tu vois pas mais j'espère
qu'on va trouver on va trouver la
solution pour
anvers ils sont avec la gueule qu'elle
est ce qu'elle est enfin je jure on
tombe là dessus y'a pas à chier on tombe
là dessus c'est très juste mais c'est
vrai débat non regardez j'ai fait
d'autres calculs donc voilà
pourquoi il aurait toujours raison
le système serait infaillible c'est pas
possible tu as tout est la faute de quoi
c'est la seule qu'on me demande était
fausse et pas bonne c'est pas de sa
faute
vous êtes génial quand florent pagny
c'est que vous arrivez en france il faut
y penser en pleine discussion sur les
retraites tout le monde s'arrache les
cheveux pour savoir s'il peut travailler
37 ans ou trente sept ans et demi vous
vous mariez vous dites que je travaille
deux mois par an et je peux pas me
impôts et je vous emmerde tout le monde
est content et du monde il est
formidable c'est florent pagny bah ouais
ouais écoute c c'est parce qu'à un
moment je me prends pas au sérieux
n'oublie pas que quelque part au milieu
de tout ce bordel gens rigolent et qu'à
la limite je suis un petit gars qui
vient d'en bas puis qui profitent de
tout ça et ça rassure tout le monde
quelque part mais certains cas c'est un
peu robin des bois comme ça le met face
à l'état pourquoi pas au fisc mais
tellement notre combat florent mais bien
sûr bien sûr mais je m'en occupe il s'en
occupe fleuron des êtes un des rares à
critiquer les intouchables restos du
coeur qui en france aux critiques et les
restos du coeur huit au départ coluche
avait voulu ça pour aider les pauvres et
maintenant ça se substitue à l'état
c'est pas ça qu'il voulait lui au départ
oui parce que lui il avait fait ça pour
prouver justement à l'état qu'ils
étaient incompétents faim qu'ils avaient
pas qu'ils pouvaient le faire et qui
c'était un mec comme lui qui était en
train de le réussir alors vous rappeler
la première fois il y avait tous les
politiques tous les partis tout le monde
s'était réunie et donc nous regarder ça
et bon g
la chance de rencontrer coluche et de le
voir en direct et de lui dire [ __ ]
c'était génial c'est génial ce que tu as
fait ça va ça va être là pour toute la
vie il nous regardait vous êtes des
congés pas fait ça pour que ça devienne
une institution j'ai fait ça pour
l'heure montré leur incapacité actuelle
donc bon lui il était parti pour leur
dire au moins prenez en charge cette
base ça coûte 25 bâton 25 millions pour
pour payer la bouffe des dépôts 25
millions dans le budget de l'état c'est
quand même pas grand chose trois paniers
au moins
tu passes
pour durer voilà alors bon après de fer
et restos moi je pensais qu'on pouvait
avoir ce discours là parce que de toute
façon même s'il est à payer 25 millions
ça nous empêchera pas de venir faire
encore le spectacle et d'en rajouter
deux mètres en galice pour apporter
encore plus qu'il y ait les bénévoles et
tous bons on n'a jamais voulu tenir ce
discours on sait pas très grave non plus
il est important que les restos du coeur
existent mais j'irai aussi un brin soli
choeur et moi on n'est jamais loin de
chercher seulement bon mais ça va je
suis encore populaire
d'autres causes
aussi pour ça que j'y vais plus trop non
plus et en solidarité à ceux qui n'y
vont pas bah oui en se disant que
quelque part il ya un dauphin est un
petit club qui se fait et puis quand
t'es pas au resto t'appartient pas et
n'ont besoin que la juste quand on était
si j'avais d'être mangés gorath aussi
long
je surveillais à bouffer je trouve ça
scandaleux certains sénateurs florent
pagny l'a ouvert rebellyon s'arrête
quand même c'est la star ac parce que
bien sûr vous dites à fort élevé des
chanteurs sous serre avec autant d'angré
ça finira comme la vache folle ça c'est
le côté négatif pour est là mais vous
dites aussi mais on etienne mougeotte
patron de tf1 pascal [ __ ] patron
d'universal me l'ont demandé et c'est
pour ça que j'y suis allé
d'abord parce que vous aviez un prime
prévue sur tf1 pouviez pas faire ça à
etienne et ensuite parce que tf1 était
co producteur du film dont nous allons
parler donc c'est à dire que même à un
moment quel que soit votre rebellion
quand on vous dit d'aller faire la star
ac vous y allez bon après tu mets ça
dans la balance ah oui puis avant tu dis
bon bah en effet politiquement c'est
correct
ensuite ça pouvait aider le film
fait du mal est là bas quand on connaît
tous ce que vous en pensez mais en même
temps ce que j'en ai pensé quand j'ai vu
l'histoire arriver et puisque je peut en
penser aujourd'hui quand je vois comment
ça évolue un certain moment ça va je me
plains pas trop d'être parent de star
académie quoi enfin bon on dit avoir été
d'avoir été à la première en même temps
si tu regarde l'émission et si tu me
veux si tu me vois dedans tu vois que
j'y suis quoi
c'est toujours plus facile à vivre
alors à parler du film justement florent
pagny c'est votre grand retour au cinéma
ça s'appelle quand je vois le soleil de
jacques ortal alors l'histoire c'est
vous vous êtes dessinateur de bd vous
vivez avec marie claude pietragalla
qu'est danseuse étoile au sommet de son
art et vous avez une fille et quand
françois cluzet qui joue le médecin vous
apprend que votre femme est atteinte
d'un cancer incurable et qu'elle est
condamnée évidemment ça vous flinguent
mais elle elle accepte pas sa maladie
doit plus dense et bien sûr elle
n'arrive pas à imaginer qu'après elle
vous aurez une autre femme voilà plus
elle s'affaiblit
plus elle prend d'emprise sur vous et
elle vous demande même d'inviter
allemand une prostituée chez vous à la
maison donc ouais ouais c'est assez
particulier un bon il faut il faut
savoir que d'abord c'est l'histoire de
l'histoire vraie du réalisateur donc à
part la transposition
de sa compagne en danseuse puisque lui
c'était avec une actrice donc bon voila
il à partir du moment où on rentre dans
une histoire vraie ben il faut accepter
les conditions aujourd'hui vous êtes le
roi du pétrole ah ouais vraiment c'est
pour ça que autant d'hectares non mais
c'est vrai alors la vie en a on avait
sérieux non j'ai un beau destin je
connais pas oui c'est vrai non je
connais pas quelqu'un qui a eu plus de
chance que vous puisque vous étiez en
bas quand une histoire vanessa paradis
place qui roule je trouve les stars qui
vous a pas été liaison que vous allez
des ouais j'ai vécu des trucs super je
suis allé gratter le sol je suis remonté
comme une flèche je me suis éloigné je
reviens ça marche moi j'ai un bol d'en
faire mais je dis toujours j'ai de la
chance dans la chance alors bon des fois
ça peut être un peu angoissante et dit
jusqu'où ça va très bien comme un
problème florent pagny ah ça y est il ya
quand même un problème emmerder sais que
vous avez beaucoup de succès mais vous
n'êtes pas encore culte et on va voir ce
que vous devriez faire pour être qu on
va faire une interview qu
alors florent pagny est ce que pour
devenir culte vous seriez prêt à être
assassiné par un fan qui viendrait vous
demandez une photographe mais jamais non
jamais contre les points en régie on va
voir s'il peut devenir culte ou pas ce
sera très simple est ce que pour devenir
culte vous accepteriez d'être malheureux
banon
vous serez jamais culte un mec clavicule
de nicholas ray regarder on dirait là il
va être culte nicolas comme ça elle
avait goûté on dirait que toute la peine
du monde s'est abattue sur lui les
filles trouve ça formidable
moi j'ai pourtant franchement
l'impression que tout ça est très
éphémère et ouais donc à un moment
d'accord en cultivent leur rêve en
culture ça mais c'est vachement bien de
vivre pour soi ouais donc est ce que
fait mon devoir est ce que pour devenir
culte vous seriez prêts là maintenant à
brûler un billet de 100 euros non
mais non mais parce que c'est ça pour la
tête à tout le monde ce genre de
conneries à me jeter un verre d'eau à la
gale pour que la wii la barre
ponsard ça ferait rire tout le monde est
ce que pour devenir culte qui vous
seriez capable de dire par exemple à
romane bohringer à want to fuck je les
ai vus mois en direct non non je me
permettre à dire au faire mais tu vois
la question qui tue falloir que tu cours
très vite dans cette attaque
et je vais même te dire je crois que je
vais m'éclater en plusieurs barrages et
jean claude tu crois que tu meures à
éviter jusqu'à la scène que les toute la
nuit bon des promesses des promesses
florent famille est ce que pour devenir
culte vous seriez prêt à mourir d'une
overdose dans les toilettes de l'hôtel
costes non non non non non surtout voilà
là oui c'est un sévère 12 de nutella
dans un formule 1 et on veut ni enfin la
sécu non mais j'ai rien à voir avec le
culte non vous auriez pas capables par
exemple d'égorger un coup les nuits sur
scène de cracher à la gueule d'un flic
plots culte un challenge non non non il
faut que ce soit cool festi géorgie
combien de
six n'ont eu aucune chance de devenir
cuisinier joe dassin la
voiture rapide et loupé un virage ça
c'est beau s'il reste un joker voulais
pas faire ça non moi j'ai un problème là
c'est que j'ai des enfants
avec les enfants génie envie qui meurent
ni envie de mourir c'est donc j'ai envie
de les voir grandir j'ai envie de laitue
voit donc j'ai vraiment envie de tout ça
j'ai envie de voir mes mômes et de
m'éclater avec eux et un vaccin quelque
chose bordel à côté l'histoire les
machins ça ne le fait pas une seconde
bon on préfère les films et les pétards
quête culte voilà d'accord j'ai compris
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu